welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
answering some of your big questions
about Leave the World Behind the brand
new Netflix movie leaves a lot of things
open-ended and throughout this video
we'll be letting you know what happens
that includes things like what caused
the apocalypse what the lady was saying
in Spanish why Archie's teeth fell out
the secret cabal and so on and so on
I've compiled this list from a number of
different sources including the director
in cast and I think there's a lot here
that clears up some of your questions
why don't you explain this to me like
I'm five the first one you probably have
is what caused the apocalypse though
neither the bucker films spell it out we
do learn certain things about what's
going on at the core of its uncertainty
and misinformation during a blackout of
communication the message of the movie
to me is not to turn on ourselves and in
these uncertain times that we have to
stick together author of the book Roman
Alam actually talked about this with
Bary and did a big interview breaking
down the movie in it he talked about the
speech with George and said what the TR
true meaning behind it was he's
describing this scenario of attack which
will induce uncertainty in the
population in a way what he's afraid of
is exactly what he's experiencing it's
just uncertainty you as a viewer have to
fill in the blanks of what uncertainty
looks like whether it's a Cyber attack
whether it's an act of War whether it's
an environmental disaster whether it's
just a collapse of Civic order that's
what's so scary about it is that you
just don't know I think this works well
in the film and we as an audience are
meant to argue about what it is you can
extrapolate this to real life and see
how uncertainty and paranoia can drive
us down certain paths it's a theme that
Oppenheimer picked up off brilliantly
and that too had struss going down a
certain route that was all because he
was uncertain over something which
eventually led to him acting in a
certain way we see the tension from this
most notably in Danny as he draws his
gun on George and Clay though George is
someone he's been friends with for years
he's still uncertain over whether he can
trust him however in the end they decide
to work together which two is
exemplified in both the families Amanda
initially starts off by not trusting
George and Ruth but in the end she sees
that she's misjudged them had she not
admitted to this misjudgment then
tensions may have escalated further and
further I think that this misjudgment in
the ends what causes Humanity to turn on
itself that's a feeling I get from this
and it tells us that in the end we need
to be friends say friends now I don't
think the theme of friends playing over
the end is any coincidence either and it
literally says I'll be there for you so
though we don't have a specific cause
for what happened it's all purely based
around that feeling of uncertainty
though George gives his thoughts that's
still just a theory but it shows the
uncertainty around the whole event being
unable to fully understand someone or
something can also cause us to be
fearful which feels exemplified in the
woman that Clay comes across speaking in
Spanish he can't understand her and you
might be wondering what it is she says
deida managed to break the whole thing
down as we don't get subtitles to tell
us what it is however she actually talks
about several things in the movie and
says thank God I found someone I'm
trying to get back to my home I'm lost
I've been walking for a while I need to
use your phone you're the first person
I've seen all day we have to get out of
here I just saw a plane that was
spraying red gas in the vicinity I saw
some deer more than 50 they were coming
out the woods please I need to go home
sir a military plane appeared and fled
there's no one around is it a chemical
attack now I'm not not sure cuz I didn't
go back and watch it I'm not sure if
when you watch it in Spanish dubbed if
it plays it in Italian or something but
either way again there's that feeling of
uncertainty now that red gas turned out
to be the Flyers which also had their
own writing on them think story managed
to get it translated and according to
him it says the following we ask you to
pay immediate attention to what we say
in this publication we have the most
dangerous and destructive explosives in
history and we leave this horrific fact
for you to contemplate and stress the
validity of what it is said I'm using
this on your land and steps must be
taken to stop the resistance built for
peaceful surrender of your land so
perhaps thatu struck with the nukes at
the end and we learned from Danny that
other countries could be involved now
flyes dropping is actually something
that happened before the atomic bombs on
Japan would drop with both key targets
being warned in advance I do think
there's validity to what was said as
well with potentially all America's
enemies coming together for this big
attack that's what you get mate that's
what you get for dumping tea in the
harbor you son of a that was me PG
tips I'll never forget
anyway just needed to get that off my
chest I suppose it wasn't that deep it
was just tea in the harbor but one thing
you might notice with the Cyber attack
announcement is that it also looks like
it has Russian writing on it several
countries are named in the film and they
may have United to pull this whole thing
off I did theorize that the nukes we see
at the end were fired by the US itself
but since then I've had a change of
heart the bunker that we see as a
message from the white house so I don't
think they would do this if they pulled
the trigger themselves either way I
think think we get a hint out to what
may have happened with the cabal that's
brought up by George he talks about how
a high ranking friend used to go off on
their holiday and they Jo they joke back
and forth about how he'd go and meet
with the evil cabal they had a laugh and
to him the world wasn't being controlled
by anyone and in the end he thought that
we were completely rudderless however I
think George he might have changed his
mind due to a conversation he had with
him just before the blackout potentially
all those out run the world lost control
and something or someone stepped up and
decided to take them down if that's the
case there of course be a power struggle
like this that may lead to innocence
getting caught in the crossfire I do
like that idea and the movie was
produced by Barack and Michelle Obama so
tin foil hat on for that one mate or is
it actually real and is it really
happening I'll let you decide and you
can decide if it's all connected now
speaking of is it all connected we've
just launched a new T-shirt with Kevin F
on the front and he's doing that thing
where he talking about is it all
connected you know the meme that we
always do he's doing that and uh if you
want to support the channel then go to
that just trying to interject a joke
because I know a lot of people are out
there sitting right now thinking bloody
hell the Obama's well involved in it GE
geez Is that real and it is real yet
they were involved so take what you want
from it with that um but I I thought
when watching the movie that it might be
aliens throughout the film we get
several shots of space that almost act
as if something's creeping over the
planet potentially natural phenomenon
affected the radio waves and that could
have cut off communication which may
have sent us into a panic what I like
though is that something like this it
can really drive you to grasp out what
you personally think would happen when
aliens were brought up with the author
he even said my first editor on the book
said to me I understand that it's
imperative that you dance around what's
really happening and then she mentioned
aliens and I was like aliens really
that's where your head went but I also
find that so pleasurable because I don't
get to control what people are thinking
and readers come to something with their
own frame of reference now whatever's
going on has clearly affected the animal
too as deers were coming together to
either attack or warness I'd love it if
we found out that it was actually the
deer that were behind it and as we know
nobody nobody ever suspects the
deer now we do get a radio broadcast
that you have to listen out for that
says whatever is happening here has
affected animals however there's a hell
of a lot of symbolism to them with dear
meaning something else Beyond just what
we see when talking to the Today's Show
Charlie Evans said dear are peaceful
creatures to turn that sweet image into
now this sort of ominous menacing almost
warning I thought thought it was really
interesting that's the trick about this
movie we always try to take the things
that we never really considered a threat
and then turn it around on them in the
novel they were supposed to symbolize
the world was changing around the
characters and in the end they were
unable to control what was going on
Evans and went on to say the connection
to the natural world how we treat it how
it moves around us and how we don't
really think about it as carefully as we
should I think that ties into the point
that Amanda brings up when she says we
have this Collective delusion that we're
treating the world as well deer are
often hunted for sport and perhaps this
could be seen as them coming back on our
last video YouTube us W tide also
brought up their own theories about how
the film Rifts on the Rapture the
eclipse is something that happens in
that and animals also lose their fear of
man user quoted numerous verses that
time with the actions in the film and I
think there's definitely a connection
there if you want to see it again a lot
of this movie is open to interpretation
with bugs also potentially causing their
own issues too this comes in the form of
Art who slowly gets iller and iller as
we get further into the film after the
noise he wakes up coughing and from here
his teeth start falling out perhaps it
was because he didn't cover his ears or
it may have been the bug that bit him
but the character is clearly edging
closer to death in the end he gets help
in the form of pills from Danny but it's
very clear that something was up with
him personally I took this being down to
either the bug being poisoness or there
being radiation in the area that caused
his cells to die off microwaves are
discussed at one point and perhaps
covering one's ears help to Shield the
effects of it look I'm not a radiation
expert mate just something to ponder and
I'm sure places like Chernobyl you know
people were affected worse than others
even though they were in the same area
either way Sam asmail brought up a
really interesting point when he was
discussing what was going on
specifically with the character he said
I want to be careful how I answer this I
think it's a nightmare I think the
movies is a nightmare and I think that
in nightmares things happen that are
inexplicable now people's teeth falling
out and dreams is something that's also
been studied in Psychology for years
this is said to be caused by the dreamer
suffering from stress or anxiety in real
life and in the end they feel like
they've lost something this definitely
fits a situation as that gir he likes
probably dead spoiler I know I know lots
of people don't like the way the film
ends I think viewing this as a metaphor
for a nightmare Works quite well they're
isolated uncertain of what's going on
and watching the world fall apart around
them which adds a lot of the things that
play out in the movie now in talking
with kider asil stated that he wanted to
start the movie off with having a dream
feeling that then devolves into a
nightmare that feels very claustrophobic
this is due to its small cast and also
the situations that they find themselves
put in I think this dream idea could be
why the paintings alter and change over
the film which is also something of you
guys pointed out on our last breakdown
now one of the last things you guys
probably want to know is whether they
made it or not in my ending explain I
played a clip of Sam asmail discussing
that they in fact did which has since
been backed up by Roman Alam I play the
clip with Sam again as that's already in
my other video but here's what alarm had
to say on it in the film they set that
timer and so there's a literal ticking
clock and we hear the timer alarm go off
that's the last moment we're with Ruth
and Amanda and the last thing that GH
has said is we've got to go to that
bunker you as a viewer may say oh
they're not going to make it but I have
this vision of GH as so competent and I
feel like he's solved every problem but
I don't know what's going to happen to
Archie the truth is that I don't know
this is something I've heard Sam say a
lot that he also doesn't know but this
is open enough that it becomes something
that's possessed by its audience I'm not
withholding a definitive answer because
I'm not in possession of that so in the
end no one knows but last of you guys
may have noticed that there's actually a
QR code in the movie which is embedded
in the map of the state this happens at
about the 34 Minute Mark and if you scan
it it takes you to visit Mercer
county.com
slpl lak shy this States Lake shy a b in
amusement park there's something
unnatural about this Mercer County
attraction a Native American burial
ground violent deaths freak accidents
who knew a simple amusement park could
have such a dark past explore this
creepy maybe cursed Land one of the
world's most haunted places arrange a
private tour join paranormal
investigators to ghost hunt or Brave the
dark carnival in October and to me that
sounds like the teaser for a show or a
film coming down the line and
potentially a good hint at what some
mma's next project is guessing that's
going to be releasing in October but
obviously we're going to find out
further down the line anyway that wraps
up the video and huge thank you for
watching our followup hopefully this
helped you enjoy the movie a little bit
more which I judge him by some of the
comments it it won't be that hard either
way thank you for watching it as we
really appreciate your support and
please drop a like on the video If you
you've had a bit of fun with it if you
want to support the channel as a member
of the spoiler Society then please also
consider clicking that join button for
99 cents a month or 99 P you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
if you want something else to watch
we've got our original breakdown on
screen now and huge thank you to
everyone who's checked that out the way
I really appreciate you guys again I've
been your host Paul you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care
[Music]
peace